leur dernier passage à l'elysée le 14
juillet dernier a laissé de mauvais
souvenirs aux jardiniers lors de la
traditionnelle garden party la ferveur
autour de l'équipe de france championne
du monde avait pour le moins ravagé la
pelouse du palais national mais bon
prince le locataire des lieux ne leur en
a pas voulu
il les a même convié à nouveau ce matin
pour une très officielle remise de la
légion d'honneur sur place laurent
frédéric bollée et jean cornu et un et
deux et trois et on ne compte plus les
célébrations la coupe du monde est à
l'elysée et les héros du mondial aussi
ses thèmes et jacquet qui la porte
mais c'est fabien barthez qui est arrivé
le premier un peu difficile de mettre la
cravate mais l'occasion en vaut
évidemment la peine
sahnoun oeuvres des jeunes donneurs
c'est vrai que ça fait c'est sympa csn
pas connaître ici bah ouais ça troisième
fois on apprend dans l'appartement
en attendant à l'applaudimètre en tout
cas mention spéciale au double buteur de
la finale
zinédine zidane
je compte sur mon nom simplement
donc ça fait 6 à mesure on va y aller
très haut
certains sont venus en famille et
s'apprête à retrouver le premier
supporter des bleus
le président de la république là c'est
facile à protocole pendant la coupe du
monde et il était tellement disponible
qu'il avait mis un petit peu de côté le
protocole finalement ça nous a dérivé
d'une certaine manière puisque il a su
nous mettre à l'aise et finalement lui
aussi contribué à ce qu'on soit dans les
meilleures conditions pour jouer cette
coupe du monde
ambiance quand même décontracté à
l'intérieur même si ça n'est pas la
garden party du 14 juillet dernier le
président n'a rien oublié et il n'est
sans doute pas le seul
merci les bleus pour ces moments uniques
que vous nous avez fait vivre
merci pour ce bonheur immense merci pour
la leçon de tolérance et d'humanité que
vous nous laissez et voilà comment se
termine une grande et belle aventure
cette semaine après la finale face au
brésil la france est fière de ses
champions du monde
le foot ça mène à tout même à la légion
d'honneur voilà une photo de famille